ja in meinen heutigen vortrag der auch
kompakt gehalten ist geht es um das
thema virtualität virtuelle realität und
didaktik als anwendungsfall der
digitalität ich möchte etwas konkreter
werden aber auch anknüpfen dann die
vorträge von herrn uliczka oben rechts
mache ich dann die gibt es ein video auf
youtube
ich will jetzt ein paar thesen
formulieren nicht ganz so viele wie frau
krämer gestern die elf thesen
präsentiert hatte wo ich auch oben
rechts im linken mache sondern nur ein
paar weniger erste these ist das
phänomen der digitalität lässt sich am
besten durch den philosophischen begriff
der virtuellen realität verstehen wir
hatten die diskussion was sagen die
basis zum verständnis der digitalität
frau krämer hat die these vertreten das
ist die differenz von analog und digital
hat darauf hingewiesen dass das digitale
schon viel älter ist als der computer
andere philosophen und philosophen wie
zum beispiel luciano flori die
argumentieren ihr von dem informations
begriff her also die sprechen dann von
der info sphäre
ich persönlich glaube dass diese
begriffe durchaus tragfähig sind aber
dass der begriff der trend realität noch
besser geeignet ist und dieses komplexe
phänomen der digitalität sowohl in
ökologischer als auch in praktischer
hinsicht zu verstehen und auch zu
begreifen
meine zweite these ist dass wir
virtuelle realität streng von
simulationen und fiktion unterscheiden
müssen also häufig denkt man wenn man
denn das wort virtuelle realität wird
also eine brille in eine brille
das ist in meinen augen ich komme gleich
noch ein bisschen mehr drauf nur eine
simulation aber keine virtuelle realität
ich verstehe also virtuelle realität
stärker monologischen sinne als
simulation
konkret heißt das virtuelle realität ist
eine reduzierte form von realität so wie
es physische realität und mentale
realität ist das lässt sich nicht
aufeinander reduzieren sowie auch
mentale realität gedanken nicht ohne
verlust auf physische realität wie zum
beispiel euro nach
strukturen oder ereignisse reduziert
werden können weitere these ist um jetzt
die simulation etwas wieder mehr
einzuholen und nicht so ganz außen vor
zu lassen ich glaube dass in der
digitalität auch in der virtuellen
realität ein sukzessiver übergang von
der simulation zur virtuellen realität
stattfindet so dass sie am ende die
virtuelle realität einer autonomen
status besitzt sich von ihrem
ursprünglichen physischen vorbild für
sich gebundenen vorbild immer mehr immer
an zitiert ist also ein gradueller
prozess und das ist nichts was sofort
einsetzt und wir bemerken dass zum
beispiel jetzt auch in der korona
situation am beispiel der virtuellen
lehre auf dass ich auch noch eingehen
werde
und das wird mich eben zu letzten these
virtuelle realität so wie ich sie
verstehe stärker jetzt ich hab' beispiel
der didaktik der digitalität konkret
illustrieren
jetzt möchte ich aber ich habe schon ein
bisschen angedeutet auf die ontologie
und die modalität der virtualität unter
der virtuellen realität etwas näher
eingehen ich habe hier ein diagramm ich
glaube wie gesagt das virtuelle realität
nur eine form von realität ist wie auch
physikalische realität und mentale
realität eine form von realität ist und
ich glaube dass wir diese formen von
realität von formen der realität
unterscheiden müssen zu denen unter
anderem die fiktion die simulation und
die illusion gehört ich will damit nicht
sagen dass diese untergliederung
vollständig ist dass man andere formen
von realität geben zudem ist zum
beispiel falls man die these vertreten
möchte und platonischer rinnen und
platonischer ist das zahlen gibt ideelle
gegenstände die wäre dann hier auch noch
um 1 ordnen dass wir jetzt also nicht
bedeuten dass es vollständig ist und mir
geht es nur darum zu sagen virtuelle
realität ist eine form von realität oder
das virtuelle ist eine formalität
so und jetzt glaube ich dass man diese
form von virtuelle realität auf formen
von der realität beziehen kann weil sich
dazu eine gewisse besitzen
ich nehme an erster stelle die
simulation an zweiter stelle aber auch
die fiktionen und wir müssen uns das
ganze wie ich schon sagte so vorstellen
dass hier das mentale als vom der
realitäten nicht ohne verlust auf das
physikalische zu reduzieren ist wie aber
auch das virtuelle nicht ohne verlust
auf die hardware basis auf die
physikalische basis zu reduzieren ist
und darin bestehen eine interessante
analogie zum mentalen und könnte sogar
so weit gehen und sagen das virtuelle
reagiert erst wenn das mentale schon auf
dem physikalischen reagiert ist als eine
form von im ergänzt zweiter stufe im
ergänzt ist immer ein problematischer
begriff damit jetzt eigentlich gar
nichts konkret gesagt wie jetzt denn das
neue entsteht ich glaube aber dass man
es vorläufig als im ergänzt beschreiben
kann die virtuelle realität er reagiert
auf physikalische realität und auf
mentalität und jetzt möchte ich noch auf
die modalitäten etwas eingehen
notwendigkeit möglichkeit wirklichkeit
glaube dass in der virtuellen realität
eine ganz interessante fusion
stattfindet die modalitäten möglichkeit
und wirklichkeiten ich hab's der
realität gelandet ist die wirklichkeit
aber auch die möglichkeiten ist ja auf
eine besondere weise noch mit aufgehoben
indem nämlich das moment der fiktion
auch einzug hält in die virtuelle
realität weil wir uns von der
ursprünglichen vorbildhaften
physikalisch gebundenen realität immer
mehr emanzipieren
also nicht mehr nur simulieren struktur
analog sondern irgendwann auch ganz neu
und kreativ werden ohne das ist eben
dabei um eine fiktion ist sondern dass
wir hier eine einheit von möglichkeit
und wirklichkeit haben das heißt in der
virtuellen realität haben wir einen
moment der fiktion wir haben einen
moment der simulation aber transformiert
und fusioniert zu
realität und das ganze könnte man jetzt
als eine form von freiheit bestimmen
wir werden unabhängig von der
physikalischen realität und kreativ und
diese autonomie ist wie ich sagen würde
eine form der virtuellen freiheit die
uns ganz viele neue handlungsoptionen
handlungsräume im digitalen raum in der
sphäre der digitalität erschließt so
jetzt zum schluss noch ein paar thesen
zur didaktik der digitalität wir können
dass meine theorie die jetzt recht
abstrakt war die ontologie der
virtualität sehr gut wie ich finde auf
die didaktische übertragen
die virtuelle lehre wie wir jetzt schon
in corona zeit erlebt haben
sie beginnt mit einer simulation der
physischen wäre also nur behelfsweise
die physisch gebundene lehre die werden
der orts bindung kennen an damit raum
und ort wie man es nennen möchte an der
universität die wand erst behelfsmäßig
simuliert man hat dann irgendwelche
virtuelle räume und erst mit der zeit
entdeckt man neue formen der iren die
sich völlig losgelöst haben von ihrem
vorbild
man könnte also sagen die virtuelle
lehre emanzipiert nicht sukzessive sind
er physisch gebundenen lehre die
ursprüngliche vogel war in dem durch
neue digitale mittel neue formen der
lehre etabliert werden und ganz wichtig
ist in diesem zusammenhang die
spezifische raume zeit logik der
digitalität wir haben es auch schon in
anderen verträgen gehört das virtuelle
oder auch die der raum der digitalität
ist nicht mehr so zeitlich zu verstehen
wie ich die frisch gebundene welt ist
zeitlichkeit spielt eine andere rolle
und natürlich auch räumlichkeit das
haben wir vorteile realisieren
virtuelle räume sind eine andere form
von räumlichkeit als physische räume
sind und diese neue räumlichkeit und
zeitlichkeit kann natürlich auch für
didaktik der digitalität fruchtbar
gemacht werden
ein beispiel am denken denken und lernen
verlaufen in der sphäre der digitalität
nicht mehr so sehr linear als vielmehr
hypertext vernetzt also das vernetzen
dem moment bekommt durch die anderen
raum und zeit logik der virtuellen
realität eine viel stärkere bedeutung
damit soll jetzt nicht gesagt sein dass
nicht auch in der physische lehre das
vernetzte denken eine rolle gespielt hat
ohne frage dass der hypertext ist älter
als das digital wie auch die virtuelle
realität älter ist als die digitalität
nur glaube ich dass ihm der sphäre der
digitalität dieses verletzten der
hypertext solle denken paradigmatisch
exemplar exemplifiziert werden kann dass
wir also ein parade von haben um dieses
diesen gedanken des hypertext zu
realisieren warum weil wie luciano für
die gesagt hat das internet nicht mehr
durch reibung gekennzeichnet ist sondern
dass wir eine ganz neue form von
unmittelbarkeit erreichen indem zum
beispiel ein klick genügt um zu einem
anderen zu kommen das ist eine viel
größere unmittelbarkeit als etwa das
blättern in einem buch um verweisen
nachzugehen und diese unmittelbarkeit
ist nicht nur etwas aktien teles nur
etwas äußerliches diesem medium sondern
es ist glaube ich intrinsisch relevant
für das medium des transportes zu einer
neuen fähre und das führt mich zum
allerletzten punkt ein kommentar zum
internet ich glaube eben nicht dass das
internet nur ein medium ist sondern ist
es vielmehr ein virtueller handlungsraum
der didaktisch fruchtbar gemacht werden
kann das heißt das eröffnet uns
möglichkeiten selbst aktiv zu werden
operationen im internet große
simulationen oder spieler ein sondern
sie sind wirkliche handlungen und
insofern müssen wir natürlich auch immer
daran denken diese handlung zu
reflektieren und gegebenenfalls auch zu
kritisieren das was wir ermitteln müssen
ist eine ethik des internets als ein
handlungsraum und nicht nur als ein
medium glauben dass diese sicht etwas zu
kurz greift und ich glaube dass man über
den bfd virtuelle realität die internet
als handlungsraum besonders gerecht
werden
so jetzt bedanke ich mich vielmals für
die aufmerksamkeit nicht nur noch am
schluss noch ein paar neue und
publikationen zu verweisen wo ich diese
thesen weiter entfaltet haben einmal in
diesem aufsatz für so viele digitalität
dann aber auch konkret zur didaktik der
digitalität flug ist ein unternehmen was
youtube und blogs nutzt aber auch
blockseminar tweed seminar wo ich der
struktur des über texas etwas näher
nachgegangen bin dann bedanke ich mich
vielmals für die aufmerksamkeit und im
beschreibungstext finden sich weiter
informationen und ich freue mich über
eine kritische diskussion